- Now, I want to bring out
one of the hottest rappers
in the game right now.
His new album is called
"Tickets to my downfall"
which is pretty much the
greatest album title ever.
And it drops tomorrow.
Let's say hello to Machine
Gun Kelly. Everybody.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheers)
- Hello
Happy to see you.
- Hey
(indistinct)
- We've hugged
- I know
It's so nice to see you.
- Nice to see you.
I am such a fan.
I've been like,
totally like you're my
Spotify playlist right now.
You've got such a cool sound.
- Wow
- I do. I love it.
I love it. I love it.
I love your pink and pearls.
We could be friends.
- I know.
- So, what do people call you like MGK
or Kelly or Kell or Machine Gun Kelly.
- I mean, my friends
abbreviating call me Kells
but I'm kind of haunted by this hairy lady
from Nashville who called
me Kale, like the salad
- That's, and nobody wants to be kale
- Yeah.
- It would be like(indistinct)
- I was like,
- so it was hard to
tell that name and feel
So, I mean, my real name's Colson.
- Okay. Colson.
Okay. I'll go.
Well, I don't know Machine
Gun Kelly is kinda cool.
- Machine Gun is awesome.
- Maybe I'm just going to say
your full name at the time.
- Yeah, yeah, I like all three.
- Really awkward.
- I like all three
- So whenever I'm writing,
I definitely put my truth in my lyrics.
And that's usually why I write.
It's cause I need to get something out
and I was looking at your lyrics
and you can be very poetic.
Can I ask you about some of them
- and kind of where it came
- Yeah of course
- Okay, so here's one.
"What is love? Love is pain.
Love is butterflies and stomach aches.
Love is looking out a window pane,
tears dripping looking
like you're in the rain."
I mean, that's so poetic.
- Thank you.
- Like where did that come from?
- I mean, lyrics mean
different things as you,
as life continues, I guess.
I mean like I just found
love for the first time.
So that, that love was actually
talking about a family love
that I was, that I, that I didn't have.
And, but, but now it kind of means to me
that loving someone is how much
you're scared to lose them.
- Wow.
- So, the like how,
however, that amount is
that you're scared to like live this life
without this person is really
how much you love them, so.
- Wow. That is wow.
Yeah. I wanna talk about
that in Therapy next week.
So what
(Kelly Clarkson laughs)
So little big town.
That was pretty awesome, right?
I mean, you're from Nashville.
You're country singers,
you're at storytellers.
That's amazing.
- That is a song.
- Yeah, we love that.
- Just beautiful
- Do I love, why, can
I love, have I loved,
(Kelly Clarkson laughs)
I'm like, jeez,
I'm like that's terrifying.
I mean, exciting is what I
meant to my therapist out there.
And here's another
"I'm overstimulated and I'm sad.
I don't expect you to understand."
I mean, I feel like a lot of
people have felt like that.
Like, you know, cause we're
always constantly going,
what does that mean to you?
Like why do you write that?
- I mean, it probably
would have meant to you,
like when the world's eyes came on you
and people were wondering
like, you know, like, well,
how could you be sad
when all of this
opportunities come to you?
And you know really it's like the fact
that you're overstimulated,
it's like, you have so much
of this, these, these things,
but they, they really don't
equal out to emotional support.
- Mmh.
- You know, they're
just like materials that
- They're fleeting.
- Yeah, they're fleeting so,
and then the following line is
"I don't expect you to understand"
because it's almost like,
I think Jim Carrey said it.
He was like, I wish everyone
in the world could experience
what it's like to be rich and famous.
Just so you can realize
that it means nothing.
- Yeah, and it's,
Coming from, I like, if
I was my poor kid self,
would be like, well, try being poor.
(Kelly Clarkson laughs)
- Yeah, yeah. Me too.
I'd say the same thing, dude.
- Me too. But I've been there.
That's what I'm saying.
Like, I've been completely dirt poor and,
and I would have made that
joke back then, but it is true.
Like you really do.
And coming back to your, you know,
the poetry with the whole
statement of love from you,
it's like, it doesn't equal out to that.
It doesn't, it's all fleeting.
And, and unless you have
like solid, like valuable,
like worth in your relationships,
it's, it's, doesn't,
it's all gonna go away.
Like it doesn't matter.
And that's coming from a
kid that came from nothing.
So, but to switch the subject,
cause I feel like I've
got you on the couch
and we're in therapy,
but you just won a
Yeah, just lay down and let
it all out, Machine Gun Kelly.
(indistinct)
(Kelly Clarkson laughs)
So you just won an MTV
moon man at the VMAS
Did that mean a lot to
you? That was so cool.
(audience applaud)
- Yeah, it was, it was most people get it
on their first album or second album
or third album or fourth album.
- Yeah.
- But I it was my fifth
album that got me in the door
for the first time.
So I'm like really
- You really earned that.
- Yeah, I did.
It was like, it was this,
it was like this album will bust for me.
I was like, should I just give up
- What am I doing?
- on all those hopes
and dreams that I had?
Like, so, I mean, I hope
that there's someone
who can just use that as a, as a metaphor
for their life that like, you
know, to continue manifesting
and never like stop chasing
your personal legend.
Cause what a shame that would have been
if I would have turned my back
- Mmh
- on this right before this happened.
And I didn't even know
that the light was on,
was at the end of the
tunnel, like right there.
You know, I just would've just
turned around and like, ah,
it's like five albums
and what I really start getting
nominated at five albums in.
- Yeah, Yes,
- Me. I'm just, yes, yes, yes.
- Yes, yes.
(Kelly Clarkson laughs)
- So basically less than here is, yes.
And your new album.
I love the title "Tickets to my downfall."
That's amazing.
And it drops that's, it's
just an amazing title
and it drops tomorrow.
So what does the title mean to you?
- I use this example of like talking
about the Goodyear Blimp,
which is probably
floating around right now.
And none of you have cared to look at it
because we see it every
day and it just exists.
But if it caught on fire
and started to crash to
the ground right now,
I'm sure all of us
would look up to the sky
and pull our phones out and
- Yeah
- you know
observe and appreciate the
sight that we're seeing,
which is really an ugly site.
It's like we only cared about it
because it's burning and
falling to the ground.
So it's kind of like, I
felt like I had more friends
around me at the worst
time in my life personally
than I ever had when I was succeeding
or having a great time.
And I was kind of like,
why is everyone here for
me crashing and burning?
Why is everyone looking
at me during this time?
Like, this sucks.
- Yeah, I know.
I also feel like,
unfortunately we're kind of
those people like just humans.
We, unless it directly
impacts us, you know,
it's like, it's almost doesn't effect us
- We are fascinated by tragedy.
- Exactly. Yeah.
Unless it like, it's, it's
hard to kind of, I don't know.
It's, it's a, it's a hard thing to grasp.
Especially when everything's
going wrong, in 2020.
- Not just the Goodyear Blimp, it's like
I mean, it's gonna get
better is what we're saying.
We're so bright and shiny
and happy and smiling.
(audience laughing)
But tomorrow you're gonna
be performing on this show
- Mmh.
And what songs will you be doing?
Cause you're doing kind
of a medley, right?
- Yeah, I'm doing my
ex's best friend as a,
- as a song.
- I love that one.
Thank you. I'm super
stoked on how that's doing.
And then since it's the
album day coming out
and I wanted to do something
that we've, we've never
done on any, anywhere
- I love that.
- Or ever.
- So it's called Jawbreaker.
- Yes. Something new as well. I love that.
"Tickets to my downfall" drops tomorrow.
Y'all got to go check
it out. It's so good.